Muslims who first began entering the
United Kingdom as destitute refugees in
search of a helping hand have sure come
a long way.
[Music]
There's no need for that. We're on the
same side, bro.
Yes, we are, bro.
What you just saw took place on October
25th in London. Large throngs of Muslim
men, all masked and dressed in black,
you know, just like and as a show of
solidarity with ISIS decided to make
their presence felt. And as usual,
foolish leftists supported the Muslims.
As you saw as the marching militants
cried out Islam's ancient war cry,
Allahu Akbar, a woke a Brit objected.
"There's no need for that," said he.
"We're all on the same side, bro." To
which one of the ISIS-like marchers
corrected him, "No, we're not." As
shocking as this recent video might be
for some, it's also just the tip of the
iceberg.
>> The European white people complaining
about immigration and Islam, first of
all, I want to tell you that Islam is
going to take over every single
square inch of
the globe.
[Applause]
promised us victory over these major
powers. One of the promises of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam is
that the day of judgment will not happen
until Islam prevails.
And we become victorious. And we will
rule the whole world.
[Music]
[Applause]
The reason The reason why we are here
because we are Muslim.
Those brothers in Palestine, they're our
brothers. That's our blood. Our Lord is
one. Our deen is one. Our rasool is one.
The solution very simple. Jihad fi
sabilillah. We have armies. We have
tanks. We have soldiers. We don't fear
anyone but Allah. We don't fear the
United Nations, the British government.
We don't give a damn. WE ONLY FEAR
ALLAH. JIHAD FI SABILILLAH. Find armies.
[Applause]
Islam is going to take over every single
square inch
of
the globe.
In order to truly understand the video
clips you've just witnessed, let's
discuss a very important Arabic word
that you've probably never heard of.
That word is ribat. Not ribbit as in a
frog, but ribat. Allow me to explain.
Soon after the historic jihad broke out
of Arabia in the 7th century, ribats
formed wherever and whenever the Muslim
invaders were forcibly stopped by
non-Muslims. There on that frontier
zone, Muslim warriors created permanent
bases to continue waging jihad on the
infidel. These strongholds were
historically known as ribats, from an
Arabic word ribat, etymologically rooted
to the idea of a tight fastening or a
joining. Or in the words of the Quran,
"O you who have believed, Muslims,
persevere and endure and remain
fastened, rabitu, verb form of ribat,
and fear Allah that you may be
successful." That's Quran 3:200. In
other words, for Muslims to be
successful, they must form tightly
fastened strongholds along the borders
of still to be conquered non-Muslim
regions. From there, they persevere and
endure, to use the Quran's words, in
their jihad to conquer and seize the
lands of the infidels. That's exactly
how the jurists defined it. The word
ribat is actually all around us, though
few recognize it. Rabat, the capital of
Morocco, is so named because it was
originally a ribat from where
devastating Muslim and Barbary pirate
raids on Spain and the Christian
Mediterranean were for centuries
launched. Similarly, have you ever heard
of the Almoravids? The name of an
important 11th-century North African
jihadist group, which I actually spent a
lot of time discussing in both Sword and
Scimitar and Defenders of the West.
Their name, Almoravids, is simply a
transliteration of the Arabic
Almoravids, which means they who fight
along the ribat. In 1086, these
Almoravids invaded Spain and crushed the
Christians at the Battle of Sagrajas.
Afterward, and as a reflection and
reminder that the Almoravid is a true
jihadist, meaning he's both militant and
pious, they erected a mountain
consisting of 2,400 Christian heads,
which they stomped atop to triumphant
cries of Allahu Akbar. Speaking of
Spain, it offers a very useful paradigm
concerning how Muslim and Christian
neighbors traditionally interacted. Soon
after the 8th-century Islamic invasion
of the Iberian Peninsula, a ribat formed
along the Duero River, separating the
Christian north from the Islamic south.
For centuries, it too became a
territory where Muslims fight for the
faith and a permanent place of the
ribat, writes Reconquista historian
Joseph O'Callaghan. As in other ribats
where Muslims abutted against
non-Muslims, a scorched no-man's-land
policy prevailed. Ibn Hudayl, a Muslim
jurist from Granada who lived around the
late 8th century, explained how the
Muslim fighters operated from that
ribat. He wrote,  "It is
permissible to set fire to the lands of
the Christian enemy, his stores of
grain, his beasts of burden, if it is
not possible for the Muslims to take
possession of them, as well as to cut
down his trees, to raze his cities to
the ground, in a word, to do everything
that might ruin him in order to hasten
the Islamization of that enemy or to
weaken him. Indeed, all this contributes
to a military triumph over him or into
forcing him to capitulate." After
explaining how the Muslims finally
devastated the Duero region of Spain,
later naming it the Great Desert, French
historian Louis Bertrand elaborated,
"To keep the northern Christians
in their place, it did not suffice to
surround them with a zone of famine and
destruction. It was necessary also to go
and sow terror and massacre among them.
If one bears in mind that this
brigandage was almost continual and that
this fury of destruction and
extermination was regarded as a work of
piety, it was a holy war against
infidels. It is not surprising that
whole regions of Spain should remain
permanently sterile. This was one of the
capital causes of the deforestation from
which the peninsula still suffers. With
what savage satisfaction and in what
pious accents do the Arab analysts tell
us of those at least biannual raids
across the ribat?
A typical phrase for praising the
devotion of a caliph is this. He
penetrated into Christian territory
where he destroyed and wrought
devastation. He devoted himself to
pillage and took many prisoners.
At the same time as they were
devastated, whole regions were
depopulated. The prolonged presence of
the Muslims therefore was a calamity for
this unhappy country of Spain. By their
system of continual raids, they kept her
for centuries in a condition of
brigandage and devastation. By the way,
this historian was writing in the early
1900s, hence the honest and politically
incorrect rendering. Another older,
arguably quintessential ribat formed
along the Muslim-Byzantine border in
Anatolia, modern-day Turkey. There, the
oldest extant Arabic manual on jihad,
Kitab al-Jihad or Book of Jihad, was
compiled by one Abdullah bin Mubarak.
Born less than a century after
Muhammad's death in 632, Mubarak
committed his life to studying and
waging jihad on this Anatolian ribat
until his death around 797 AD. According
to one modern historian, Mubarak
"served as a model of zeal in
volunteering. His piety and asceticism
gave him enormous strength. He was known
to bellow like a bull or cow being
slaughtered when warring on infidels.
And his fellows continued to be drawn to
his power after his death."
Anyway, his Book of Jihad remains a
classic among militant Muslims around
the world till this day. With the coming
and military successes of the Ottoman
Turks, the Anatolian ribat we were just
talking about continued edging westward
until it finally consumed
Constantinople, the last bastion of the
Eastern Roman Empire and most of the
Balkans, reaching as far north as Vienna
twice, in 1529 and 1683. Okay, so what's
my point with this historic exposition
on the nature and role of this word that
sounds like a frog's croak? Simple.
Ribat is fundamental to understanding
Islam's position in the West. Because
Muhammad's creed is inherently tribal,
going so far as to demand that all
Muslims hate all non-Muslims, see this
video, once in a Western locale, far
from assimilating, most Muslims form
ghettos and no-go zones where
radicalization prevails.
[Music]
[Applause]
>> In other words, they instinctively form
rabats, bastions of Islamization and
jihadist sentiment, from which they
threaten, bully, and terrorize the
infidels across the way. Or nowadays,
the infidels across the street, as you
just saw in those videos.
Which, of course, leads to the primary
difference between past and present
rabats.
As seen historically, they formed
wherever non-Muslims, including
Europeans, forcibly stopped the Muslim
advance.
Today's rabats, on the other hand, are
not located along the borders of Muslim
and non-Muslim regions, but rather right
smack in the middle of European nations
and their largest, often capital,
cities. In other words, those entering
and turning Western regions into Islamic
enclaves did not do so by force of arms
the way they had to historically, but
rather because they were welcomed in
with open arms.
Until this very moment, those who
welcomed them in, that is, the ruling
class or elite of Europe, are doing
everything in their power to continue
empowering Muslims and spreading Islam
throughout Europe, including by shutting
down and even imprisoning those native
Europeans who dare speak up.
In short, the reason rabats are a
problem throughout the West is entirely
due to Western, that is, internal
actions. Muslims, on the other hand, are
simply doing what Muslims have always
done. It's your duly elected leaders who
supposedly represent you who have
changed.